well Mr President Mr President I just
come over to you Mr Prime Minister
it's great to have you back and uh you
know the past few months we've met each
other in San Diego and then we met in uh
Belfast and we met in Hiroshima
and now we're here we're going to solve
all the problems in the world right in
this next 20 minutes but uh
um you know uh
prime minister uh Churchill in Roosevelt
met here a little over 70 years ago
and they asserted the strength of the
partnership between Great Britain the
United States was the strength of the
Free World
thinks there's truth to that associate
and together we're providing economic
humanitarian Aid and security Assistance
Center Ukraine and their fight against a
brutal invasion of the Russians and uh
we've worked out the arrangement with
August
Australia and make the Indian notion of
the whole area safer more secure and uh
and uh you know we've built on the
Good Friday agreement 25 years
talk about that a little bit there's
NATO allies we're working together to
help provide to Collective defense
of all of us and we're going to further
I hope we can discuss today plans the
further strength of our economic
relationship
and the global economy is undergoing I
think the greatest transformation that's
occurred since the Industrial Revolution
it's something you know a lot about AI
is a big part in that I want you to use
on that as well
and uh we don't have a closer Ally
we've written in the library here
Mr President thank you thank you for the
warm words but also thank you for
welcoming me to the White House and for
allowing me to to stay in Blair House
which I've got to say the the spare room
in the flat in number 10 Downing Street
doesn't quite compare so it's been a
real privilege and as you said it's
daunting to think of the conversations
that our predecessors had in this room
when they had to speak of wars that they
fought together peace one together an
incredible change in the lives of our
citizens and again for the first time in
over half a century we Face a war on the
European continent and as we've done
before the US and the UK have stood
together to support Ukraine
and stand up for the values of democracy
and freedom and make sure that they
Prevail as I know we will but also I
completely agree with what you said our
economies are seeing perhaps the biggest
transformation since the Industrial
Revolution as new technologies provide
incredible opportunities but also give
our adversaries more tools for harm but
one thing I know won't change I'm
confident won't change is the strength
that our partnership our friendship and
we will put our values front and center
as we've always done to deliver for the
British and American people if we had
time I'd take you over the residence
where I live
and when you were over in Blair House
the President Truman was there because
they were redoing the White House he put
a hold of the Truman balconies they
exists now because of Warehouse
of that second balcony you see the First
Baptist
so any rate uh and there's an awful lot
of stories that are told probably a
bunch of Pocketful about uh
um
former prime minister I'd like to take
baths anyway wandering around at three
in the morning yeah Winston Church we're
bothering uh bothering Mrs Roosevelt yes
don't worry you won't see me that uh
bothering you and the first lady anyway
welcome